today we're going to look at opening
principles that everyone needs to know
when they begin playing chess and the
first thing a lot of players will tell
you different things that you need to
know about openings now while it is very
important to know some openings you want
to be familiar with some of the more
popular the Kings opening the Queen's
opening the Queen's Gambit the King's
game at the English although it's
important to know some of the common
openings it's more important to know the
opening principles behind them and those
opening principles are what we're going
to go over today even if you didn't know
any chess opening if you knew chess
principles in the opening you'd be much
better off and that's what a lot of
beginners struggle with is they memorize
these openings and have no idea why
they're moving them because they don't
know the fundamentals behind the
principles and then they end up
struggling because they're chess game is
revolves around memorization of four or
five moves when they really haven't
focused on learning how to play chess so
a couple things that you want to keep in
mind any time in the beginning of chess
you want to have a few things in the
back your head first you want to have
Center control you don't want to start
out with a move like h4 that doesn't
control the center second
you want to have King safety right now
both sides have King safety but once
place to start moving around you want to
actually have your King in a safer
position than it is now and we'll go
over what that looked like now you will
see a lot of abstract moves from a lot
of players that doesn't mean they're the
best moves you want to make sure that
you have Center control and you want to
have King safety another thing you want
to look at is you would really like to
develop your nights before Bishop's a
lot of people one of the most common
moves you'll see is pawn to e4 is the
beginning you may see pawn d5 or excuse
me pawn d4 but pawn to e4 is one of the
most common openings than you'll see
from here you'll see Knight to f3 as the
second move and you'll see this because
you normally want to open your Knights
before your bishops it's not the most
important thing in the world it's just
usually a common thing that you'll see
most people you would like to open up
your Knights before your bishops just
something to keep in mind another thing
you want to keep in mind is you don't
want to move your pawns in front of your
King more than you have to so let's say
you've developed
let's say you've developed your pieces
you've brought your Bishop to c4 you
brought your knight to f3 another King
another thing you want to think about is
you want to develop the pieces first to
the side that you're going to Castle so
if I'm going to Castle queenside it's
really not going to help me if I develop
all my pieces on my Kings side because
now I still have three pieces on my kit
on my Queen side that I have to move
before I can castle and remember Center
control and King safety so you want to
make sure that you're developing pieces
to the most people are going to Castle
kingside
so most of the time you're going to see
people develop their knight and then
they're going to develop your Bishop you
want to get your pieces center control
as you can see we have great Center
control with a pawn and our are minor
pieces and now we're going to Castle
kingside we have great Center control
and now we have King safety but we want
to be very careful because from here a
lot of players make a lot of mistakes
and they'll move a play like g4 this is
not a good play special E if we don't
have to you want to make sure that when
you have King safety you keep king
safety you don't want to move your pawns
in front of your kings if you don't have
to because it lets pieces come in here
and attack our King is a piece can sneak
in here to h3 and then get to g2 and
checkmate our King you really don't want
to do that another thing you want to do
obviously we'd like to develop our our
bishops we want to get our our excuse me
develop our pawns we want to get our
other bishops into the thing into the
action
so let's say we bring our Bishop into
the action and then our queen another
thing you want to do and that may look
something like this we bring our Bishop
to f4 again black can't move but he's
not moving yet we're just going over
what you may want your opening to look
like we move our Queen to detune we've
connected our rooks
always know that the rooks work well if
they're connected and they work even
better if there's an open file so let's
say one of your pawns were to go down on
let's say e4 you would immediately want
to put your quote your rook on the
e-file because it's an open file now the
rook has even more room to go if a rook
is blocked in he doesn't have a lot of
room to go then he's not as powerful
he's worth five pieces but if he can't
move what good is he to you so as soon
as you see an open file even if there's
a knight in the way you still want to
have your rooks on those open files
they're much much dangerous even if
they're not immediate threat later on
down the road they will not only support
your own pieces but to put a lot of
pressure on your opponent's you always
want to make sure that you can connect
your rooks early and that you have them
on open files that's very important
second thing you want to make sure that
you don't do is you don't want to move
pieces more than once early on in a game
and if you've seen the intro to the
Queens move it's similar to this it
would be the thought process of if we
start at efore and black responds d5 and
we capture and they capture with their
queen
we developer Knight to c3 now let's say
the Queen he's obviously not going to do
this he might you never know but let's
say he moves his queen to g5 I'm going
over principle here's principals again
remember you want to have principles in
your head not necessarily memorize moves
if he moves his Queen to g5 we can now
develop another piece our Knight to f3
and we're forcing the Queen to move
we're attacking he's got to move let's
say he makes a move like Queen to h6
we can now develop our pawn to d4 and we
have a discovered attack we're attacking
the Queen with our bishop let's say he
moves his Queen to f6 we can now bring
our our Bishop into the game developing
our Bishop getting him more active and
he can't take our Bishop because of our
Knight so let's say he moves his Queen
to f5 we can now develop our Bishop our
LightSquared Bishop to d3 attacking the
Queen let's say he moves his Queen to g4
attacking this pawn on g2 we can now
Castle kingside now if you look at the
setup black has only moved one piece
he's moved his Queen we have developed
all our minor pieces we have sinner
control we have King safety we can now
move our Queen connect our rooks we can
put a rook on e 1 we can control the
e-file this is going to be an extremely
strongly good game for white and black
is going to be using the next four five
six seven moves trying to develop his
pieces trying to get some sort of
counter play on the King side and at the
same time trying to get some sort of
King safety so make sure that when
you're playing you don't move your piece
more than once if you don't have to
early on so these are some of the things
you want to think about and also
this example you saw I brought my King
out early for black you don't want to
bring your queen out early if you don't
have to you want to keep him back you
want to develop your Knights first then
your bishops and then you want to have
your queen support those pieces in any
attack that you have so these are some
of the key concepts you want to think
about in opening you don't want to
memorize moves you want to know
different openings obviously but more
importantly you want to know principles
behind those so hopefully you enjoy this
and hopefully you learned a lot thanks
for watching